developers often need a way to generate
temporary credentials to access their
cloud accounts in this video we'll show
you how to generate temporary Google
cloud platform
I am credentials I've needed you think a
Shakur bolt hi I'm Emily an engineer
working on Google cloud platform and
open source integrations between cloud
and hash for bolt and I'm Andy a product
manager at Hacha Corp on the vault team
vault the secrets management tool that
allows you to store manage and control
access to tokens passwords certificates
and other types of Secrets in our last
video we used hash acquired vault to
secure an API key for a tea style arcade
game hyperspace and gave our GC
instances an easy way to access secrets
on DCP using vault now let's talk about
other ways we can you fall on gtp let's
say we want to add a daily leaderboard
to our video game we'll have an update
at midnight each day who needs to access
our video game data stored in spanner at
least once a day should we just give it
its own service account key and access
toward its banner database
well what happens if someone steals the
service account key if you don't have it
locked down as well as the main abbot
and it's all an automated process
how would you detect if it gets stolen
that won't be good what if you just gave
it temporary access to your project like
a temporary I am crucial yeah that would
work you check out the GCP secrets back
end for vault then a secret back-end in
Hashi Court vault is a pluggable
interface that can store generate or
alter secrets the GCP secrets pack end
dynamically creates a LOF access tokens
based on IAM service accounts and
policies this means you can generate
credentials to access GCP as needed
without needing to worry about how long
those credentials lost that actually
sounds like exactly what I need if I
could see how this would be useful in
other cases to things like batch jobs or
virtual training accounts don't need
access to your GCP project for very long
but can be hard to clean up after
developers could use vaults GCP secrets
beckon to assign the minimum permissions
to their initial service accounts and
I've obtained additional permissions
only as needed let me try it out sure so
if you can see we already have our vault
server up and running on GCP from last
time we'll show you how a server admin
sets up the GCP secrets back-end and how
a user obtains a new secret or a GC POS
access token
the admin needs to add configuration
details such as credentials the vault
server uses this config to make requests
to GCP to set up AI impressions next
admin needs to add vault specific role
sets these determine what permissions a
service account is created by vault will
have the bindings argument is a
configuration file where we specified G
cpi-m roles to assign to each resource
we take a closer look at this bindings
config file sure each block in the
configuration file specifies a resource
and a set of iam roles have you can see
in this block we've given the resource
name for a spanner database that
contains our scoring data and the role
of database reader
this tells the vault to give generated
service accounts permissions to read the
scoring data from the given database so
the secrets backend is set up then right
yep let's switch to a different terminal
now and show how our leaderboard up gets
an access token to obtain our auth
access token we read from the creds
endpoint specifying the rule set we want
to generate the token under vault
generates the token using a service
account it creates and then returns us
token when the TTL are time to live is
up vault revoke Solis and the access
token in turn we can then use this oh ah
spoken to call the spanner API now that
we've finished a request a spinner
we don't need access let's revoke this
token manually that was really easy to
do and if other developers have
questions on setting this back end up
where can they get more information so
check out the vault project that IO page
and look up documentation on the GCV
secrets backend
thank Vandy you can also check out other
information for running vault on GCP
including using the GCP authentication
backends or using gzp with other high
shakur tools like terraform if you the
links in the description below bye bye
thanks everyone for watching we hope you
found this series on using has your
vault with GCD helpful check out the
links in the description below and don't
forget to subscribe to the channel